in Chapter 13 of Avaya thon Hobbs laid
out what he took to be the natural
condition of humankind outside of any
sort of civil society lacking any sort
of government and extra power that could
enforce moral or legal norms and as
we've seen it's not a very pretty
picture life becomes nasty brutish and
short in part because we're led into
conflict with each other not necessarily
all the time but sooner or later and we
can't rely upon ourselves being safe and
enjoying and then any sort of prosperity
any sort of security towards the end of
chapter 13 he says reason suggests to us
articles of peace these are the laws of
nature and he also talks about several
as what we might call useful passions
and remember passions are things that
are stemming ultimately from our desires
and our versions they're expressions of
those they're part of what it means to
have a living body and these are things
that he thinks that you can take for
granted in if not necessarily everybody
pretty much close to that the vast
generality of human beings we fear death
and in the state of nature you have to
fear death nearly all the time because
unless you manage to win the lottery and
become so powerful that you can as he
says over master all other all of their
men you're gonna be liable to get killed
by some guy who comes down the road and
wants what you have or doesn't like the
way that you're looking at him or thinks
you know that guy looks kind of tough
I'd better kill him before he kills me
so fear of death is ubiquitous in the
state of nature but that's something
that can actually get us out of the
state of nature that's not quite enough
to get us to move that way we need
further motivation one of those is he
has a different phrase he doesn't say
nice things but that's the way we talk
about it today
right like when you tell people we can't
have any nice things he calls a desire
or of such things as are necessary to
commodious living that's nice things
that's the sort of things that people
like to have no again in the state of
nature could you have anything like that
could you have a nice yard could you
have a nice house or apartment could you
have a nice car could you have any sort
of nice clothes no because people would
take them away from you or you'd have to
fight all the time for them and they
probably get wrecked in the process and
even if they didn't you constantly be
worried about it so there wouldn't
actually be anybody to produce any nice
things either the last thing that he
says is we also need hope
remember what hope is hope is a desire
that has some sort of expectation of
being fulfilled so he says that you know
hope by their industry to obtain the
things that are necessary for commodious
living the nice things once we have
those desire in place desires
sorry and we start to reason about well
how would I actually get these things
we're ready to move out of the state of
nature so you can say that the fuel
comes from the passions but it's really
reason that distinctively human faculty
that gets us out of the state of nature
remember too that reason is something
that we have the capacity for but we
have to develop which means that not
everybody is going to automatically
reason out what it is that Hobbes is is
saying we ought to be able to do that's
a sort of in principle now when we do
that we come up with what he calls laws
of nature or articles of peace when he
says a law of nature
Lexx Naturalis in Latin is a preceptor
general rule found out by reason by
which a
man is forbidden to do that which is
destructive of his life that which is
going to you know lead to death or which
taketh away the means of preserving the
same and to admit that by which he
thinks it may be best preserved so a law
of nature is something it's a it's an
imperative it's a rule that reason in us
not reason coming from God above or
anything like that but reason in us says
look dummy don't do that because if you
do that you're gonna get killed or you
know hey if you want these nice things
what do you need to do in order to get
them I'm being a little facetious there
but you could think about reason in us
as sort of that you know that that voice
internally that's saying I think you
should consider this this would be a
good idea for you to do so what are
these laws of nature Hobbes he actually
has you know quite a few of them I'm not
going to talk about every single one
because they're not all is relevant to
our particular emphasis in this class
but the first three are really important
because the first three are going to
lead us and what we call a social
contract this notion of the social
contract is not unique to Hobbes but he
is one of the very important early
promoters of this idea so when people
talk in in contemporary moral debates
about well what about the social
contract or haven't you you know made an
implicit social contract in part that
thought is is going back to Hobbes and
Hobbes thinks that it's reason that
suggests to us what the social contract
ought to be so the very first law of
nature has two parts human beings ought
to seek peace if possible why should
they seek peace because think about it
if they're afraid of dying and they want
to have nice things and they would you
know have the hope of obtaining them
then what's going to be the necessary
means to having that it sure isn't gonna
be being at war with everybody or being
in potential conflict it's gonna be to
have some sort of state of lasting peace
so as Hobbs says you know the first
branch is seek peace and follow it that
means do what it takes in order to
attain and maintain a condition of peace
a condition in which you're not in
conflict with others that's if it's
possible if it's not possible that's
where the second part comes about
protect yourself by any means necessary
Hobbes is willing to say that if you
cannot come to an agreement with other
people and you know they might kill you
go ahead and kill all because if they
will come into an agreement with you if
they won't enter into society with you
they're gonna be dangerous if you're
willing to do what it takes to have a
social contract in place so everybody
can be more or less happy more or less
secure and they're not willing to do it
you have to use every means available at
your disposal to protect yourself
because nobody else is going to do it
according to Hobbes so he says from this
fundamental law of nature by which men
are commanded to endeavor peace that is
to strive for peace is to ride the
second law die paraphrased it a little
bit give up some of the rights if others
are willing to do some what Hobbes
actually says is a little bit more
complex he says a man be willing when
others are so - as far forth as for
peace and defense of himself he shall
think it necessary to lay down this
right to all things and be contented
with so much Liberty against other men
as he would allow other men against
himself so a lot of moving parts to that
phrase right let's sort of work through
them one at a time if other people are
willing to live in a state of peace then
we don't have to do this thing about you
know protecting our self even if it
means killing everybody else in the
world instead when we
as we can start to think about well what
would that actually take what do I need
to give up what do I want them to give
up as well and it's going to be a more
or less you know level playing field
there's going to be a quality if I give
something up you're going to give that
same thing up because I'm not giving it
up unless you're gonna do the same thing
if I'm going to say I'm not going to go
into your cupboards and take your canned
goods you better not be doing that to me
if you know if we're going to get as
prescriptive as saying no loud music
after 10 if that applies to me that
applies to you as well there's no
favorites at least at this point we'll
see that there's one favor coming up but
there's no favorites for the human
beings contracting out of the state of
nature into the social contract no
notice that you have to give some things
up in order to do this he says yeah I
will lay down this write to all things
that I enjoy in the state of nature and
be contented not just saying oh you know
I'll try to get over on you or something
like that but I'll be contented with as
much Liberty against other people as I
allow them against myself
so if I am willing to allow them to say
mean things about me I get to say mean
things about them if I don't want them
to say mean things about me I don't get
to say mean things about them and so on
and so on so you know we rule out
certain things like stealing or killing
or you know breaking and entering or
turning each other's cars over or
setting booby traps you know there's
there's a whole bunch of things that we
would have to rule out on these these
thing these sort of Kankan conditions
conditions and considerations brain
slowed down there for a second
third law this one kind of summons them
up I'm going to come back to the second
law in a minute cuz he has a lot more to
say about what goes into this the third
law is at the beginning of chapter 15
and he says that what it consisted is
that men should perform their contracts
made meaning that if
make an agreement with you I should
follow throughout that agreement why
well because if I don't then the social
contract is gonna break down and then
I'm back in the state of nature where
I'm probably gonna die and I'm not going
to have the nice things that I want and
nobody's gonna have any nice things
nobody's gonna make any nice things and
it's gonna be worse for everybody so not
only do I have to abide by the basic
fundamental we all agree to do this but
if I make an agreement with you I need
to follow through on that agreement
because otherwise I'm risking throwing
society into chaos I'm treating myself
as if I have the right to throw it all
away just because I want some temporary
advantage now I said that we'd come back
to this notion in a second of
contracting what is contracting says
that means laying down a right to
vesting oneself of some Liberty B and
how do we do this he says well we can do
it either by renouncing it or by
transferring it to another so if I have
a right to carry this piece of chalk and
I give up that right I can't carry the
piece of truck anymore but I could give
it to somebody else and say that person
will have that right we could do this
with say killing we could say well the
rest of us can't kill anybody even if
that person is being mean to us or
scaring at us or something like that but
we will transfer that right to somebody
else who will have the power to do that
without thereby destroying the social
contract now there are a number of other
rules and these are all in chapter 15
that we do want to look at some of them
are quite important some of them are a
little bit less important there's one
for example about you know if somebody's
coming with a white flag you don't shoot
at them doesn't really apply too much to
our circumstances but many of these do
apply to to our condition right now so
the third one as we saw is you know men
perform their covenants made if you
don't
have that that when people make
agreements with each other nobody's
going to trust anyone and you're not
gonna have a social contract you're
gonna have the state of nature just you
know with a little bit of lip service to
this and people are gonna start acting
like fools again and attacking each
other and it's gonna break down so what
else do we need to do he talks about
several other laws of nature and here we
go he says as justice depends on
antecedent covenant any of this justice
depends on an agreement
so does gratitude depend on antecedent
grace it's interesting isn't it that
Hobbes is going to bring up gratitude
and something that we should build into
the social contract something that we
want to see is a law of nature now what
does it mean to be grateful hobbes sets
the bar pretty low he is his actual
formulation is that there we go
a man who receives benefit from another
of mere grace that is you know without
some requirement endeavor that he which
giveth it have no reasonable cause to
repent him of his good will so somebody
does something nice for us we don't act
like a jerk to them we don't make them
say oh I shouldn't have done that that's
a little bit you know like I said that's
setting the bar a little bit low for
what gratitude counts as you know he
doesn't even say like you need to say a
thank you or anything like that but it's
it's interesting to see that a trait
like gratitude would be built into the
laws of nature and be part of the social
contract it's part of what you need in
order to have a well-functioning society
we can't all be ingrates we can't all
expect things of each other even if we
have no right to them he goes on and he
says that you know here's the reason no
man giveth but with intention of good to
himself and so if
or you know giving to other people and
they act like jerks towards us we're
gonna stop giving and then society is
not going to work as well he goes on and
he says a fifth law of nature is
complaisance that is to say every person
should strive to accommodate himself or
herself to the rest don't be a person
who you know requires that everybody
else change around you be complacent not
complacent in the sense of like sitting
back but complacent in the sense that
you can get along with other people he
says we may consider that there is in
men's aptness to society a diversity of
nature
rising from there diversity of
affections not unlike to that we see in
Stella's brought together for the
building of an edifice so don't be the
stone that's all crooked and can't be
fit in with the others because then
they're just going to throw you out
you're not going to be in the social
contract if you can't get along with
other people if you can you can be part
of one big room he then talks about some
other laws that he have to do with how
we deal with people breaking the rules
who says a sixth law of nature is upon
caution of the future time a man ought
to part in the offenses past of them
that repenting desire it pardoning
doesn't mean like liking them or
anything like that just means saying I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna take any revenge
on you that's something that we do need
in order to maintain a society in part
because a lot of times people will give
offense without even realizing that
they're giving offense without intending
to do it and if we take offense and then
act on that offense at every possible
you know opportunity we're going to be
back in the state of nature again in the
seventh fly says in revenge's that is
retribution of evil for evil men look
not at the greatness of the evil past
but the greatness of the good to follow
so for example when we're punishing
criminals should we punish them you know
just because we get a kick out of
hurting them or we say look you killed
somebody so they're a new tortured
somebody so therefore we're going to
torture you and kill you or should we do
what's needed for the benefit of society
for what we call
turrets for the good to come in the
future he talks about an eighth law of
nature very very important one he says
no person by deed word countenance
that's near your face or gesture declare
hatred or contempt of another that's an
interesting one isn't it not really
followed in our society certainly not in
social media where you know liberals and
conservatives say horrible things about
each other religious people and anti
religious people say horrible things
about each other how does it say look if
you're doing that you're actually
setting yourself up to rip the fabric of
society apart reason should suggest to
you that if you if you're motivated by
these things you follow the laws of
nature and you don't call people mean
names you don't you know show that you
dislike people you try to get along with
them if you can't say I'll remember you
can't say something nice don't say
something at all Hobbes would say he
says this law to pet is another at the
entrance and the conditions of peace no
person required to reserve to himself
any right which he has not content
should be reserved to anyone of the rest
so we treat everybody else as having the
same rights as ourselves we don't set
ourselves above other people he's got
another one that if you know if
somebody's trusted to judge if we're put
out a jury if we're we're put in a
position of authority
it's a precept of the law of nature that
you deal equally with people you treat
similar cases similarly you don't play
favorites again why because if you start
playing favorites you're risking
throwing society into chaos he goes out
he's got a lot of other laws I'm not
going to go through all of these in part
because you know you see where this is
going what I want to finish up with
talking about it is asking the question
is this enough and clearly for Hobbes
the answer is no why he argues that
need something else in the mix something
that he calls us up or we could call
Authority or government why do we need
this if we're rational creatures if we
can see that this is the way that we
want to behave if we've got this whole
list of you know character traits that
we ought to be developing like fairness
or gratitude or agreeableness or you
know mild temper why can't we just have
a social contract and say hey we're all
gonna agree to act this way each of you
is on your own I'll let you take care of
your side of the street I'll keep my
side of the street clean well Hobbs says
that's not going to work and when we go
back to this we can only seek peace if
it's really possible and given human
nature given the fact that people do
change their minds over time and we do
tend to see things from our own egoistic
selfish perspective and we do tend to
have these you know character traits
that are different than the ones that we
need in the state of nature if you don't
have some sort of authority there in
place to punish those who break the
social contract pretty soon people are
ready to break the social contract as a
matter of fact some will break the
social contract it's not just whether
it's broken
it's how often it's broken and whether
it leads eventually to the social
contractors being nullified
so the sovereigns is what keeps the
social contract in place as you know the
level playing field for the rest of us
but that means that the sovereign he has
to be above us so it's not really a
completely level playing field the
government the authority has to have not
only more power than the rest of us but
the power to punish including the
ultimate punishment which is death it
has to be able to banish us it has to be
able to tell us what to do
matter of fact Hobbs and in reading
selections that I didn't have you go
through but in other parts Leviathan
will saying that the sovereign if it's
really taking its job seriously can't
even allow other people to express their
displeasure or you know criticism of the
sovereign and any philosophies or any
religious standpoints or any other stand
points that would call into question the
absolute authority the sovereign need to
be banished from the Hobbesian
Commonwealth so that you're going to
have a good society so that people
aren't going to break the rule so that
everybody can live in harmony so that
these passions can actually be fulfilled
now that's kind of a hard bargain isn't
it this is something that you should
really put a lot of thought into if
we're going to have a social contract on
the one hand what is going to make us
actually follow it are we good enough
people to follow it on our own if we
were we probably wouldn't need a social
contract would we because then the state
of nature wouldn't be so bad and we
wouldn't need all these rules to get
ourselves out of it on the other hand do
we want an all-powerful Absolut absolute
vodka Absolut sovereign that would have
so much power that would that would be
so high above all the rest of us and
control our lives to such a drastic
extent is that worth leaving the state
of nature for Hobbes thinks that it is
Hobbes thinks that nothing is worse than
the state of nature even having some
idiot who you know has corrupt ministers
you know they're not going to last very
long as a sovereign but even that is
better because you still have the social
contract in place than the state of war
of all against all we might not see it
that way and not all other theorists did